[Musique]
rappelez-vous d'elvis ce jeune étudiant
kosovar de 17 ans sans papiers
arrivé en france à l'âge de 5 ans elvis
est avec no mercy elvis merci certains
merci pour ma mutation il est menacé
d'expulsion et nous avions décidé de
mettre en lumière son histoire sur notre
plateau mercredi dernier je peux me
faire rattraper tout moment et être
renvoyé je puise pas serainement jeu
même quand je suis chez moi je suis pas
tranquille
un témoignage poignant qui a touché les
internautes et qui a visiblement aidé à
ce que la parole de ce jeune homme soit
entendu ce soir et le visage rami est
avec nous et il a une grande nouvelle à
nous annoncer et affichent elles disent
est avec nous et on est content monaldi
certaines très bonne nouvelle à nous
annoncer
elle a été annoncée sur par toi même sur
les réseaux
elle raconte nous ce qui t'arrive alors
ma mère va être régularisé d'un titre de
séjour dans trois semaines
ces manifs et pendant ce temps là il
aura un récépissé avec un doigt travail
que keller expirait aujourd'hui d'accord
et je vous remercie énormément je suis
là pour pour vous remercier pour vous
montrer que la solidarité et l'union
fait la force
merci beaucoup euros pour trois sièges
il ya plein de gens qui sont mobilisés
un rappel boukman aussi que j'embrasse
aussi qui a été formidable là dessus et
quand vous comment tu l'as a pris
raconte moi c'était un truc de fou alors
d'abord ma mère elle a eu un rendez-vous
à la profession le mardi enfin
aujourd'hui du coup le matin donc
aujourd'hui borné mardi west coast et du
coup elle est allée à la préfecture et
ils y ont donné un récépissé avec ans de
travail ils y ont dit comme quoi faut
attendre trois semaines environ
et elle aura un titre de séjour et et et
toi c'est bon oui moi moi je fais partie
du dossier de ma mère du coup c'est bon
jeu avec comme autres associés quand
même assure constance pourquoi voulez
vous je suis très très franchement alors
là tu vas kiffer que tu vas faire plus
tard alors maintenant toujours experts
comptables été recontacté que j'étais
dans l'expertise-comptable frérot au
travail ensemble je vous entends cabinet
est battue très heureux pour toi merci
beaucoup je sois là ce soir avec nous
arrive c'est mon cadeau je serai à ma
demande justement juste un truc des
beaux gosses talent mais un petit col
roulé était magnifique tu es heureux je
suis heureux pour toi merci beaucoup
moins c'est des copains étaient contents
il était très content vraiment il était
ému et
y'en a ils croyaient pas c'est ça leur
faisait bizarre là ils mettent time of
n'ont pas encore sûr à dossier toujours
pas je suis rapaille mama hqe attention
je me demande ce n'était pas voulu
risquer aussi pour la suite et il sur un
dossier sentiment non tout va bien tout
va bien et surtout toi c'était pas de
route a déjà repéré de 3,9 et je peux te
comprendre
merci en tout cas d'être la elvis et je
suis très très très heureux pour toi
merci vraiment vraiment mon chéri